welcome to Hari sagas a channel where we
discussed the latest tech news and of
into newest tech products today we were
looking at the top six things that
usually considered before buying the gtx
1180 but before we delve into that make
sure to hit that subscribe button if you
guys like to stay updated with the
latest tech news related to gaming and
pcs so jumping straight in with number
one the first thing that you guys should
consider is do you really need that much
performance the gtx 1180
is expected to have the same raw
horsepower as the gtx 1080i but also
have other perks like GTA 6 memory and
the tall nanometer process and maybe
even have tens of course and ray-tracing
technology the 12 nanometer process the
new tearing architecture and a GTD r6
memory alone will boost the gtx 1180
over the gtx 980ti by about 20 frames
per second but if there is ray-tracing
intensive course the difference will be
a lot higher now while this is a great
at all do you really need that much
performance and can you even take
advantage of it why are you even buying
a GPU in the first place is it for video
editing is it for gaming is it for 3d
modeling you really need to answer that
to see how much performance you really
need once you answer that you need to
think about what level you need for
example are you gaming at 1080p are you
gaming at 4k are you making 4k videos do
you make money off what you do with
editing videos all these will help you
determine if you really need that much
performance so moving on to number two
number two is price are you willing to
spend $700 for the gtx 1180 and are you
sure that that is where you want to
spend your money $700 is a lot of money
and while the gtx 1180 is definitely
worth that price is that price okay with
you also are you sure you want to spend
such a bulk amount on a single piece of
PC hardware for example if you're in
gaming it may be better for you to just
get a gtx 1170 and use your save money
to get better peripherals like a
mechanical keyboard or gaming mouse
those may improve your gaming experience
much more than just a
of frames or resolution level if you're
video editing you may want to get a gtx
1170 m 711 ad and use that money to get
better ram if you have like ddr3 ram for
example the ddr4 ram will definitely
improve your render speeds much more
than the gtx 1180 would over a gtx 1170
so make sure to consider not just if
this is affordable but if this is where
you want to spend on your money at next
up will be on to number three how long
have you been waiting how badly do you
need an upgrade and when are you
planning to buy the gtx 1180 if you have
been waiting for a really long time and
really need an upgrade then you should
definitely consider pre-ordering instead
of waiting for the gtx 1180 to come out
and watching some performance and review
videos about it because by then the gtx
1180 will most likely increase in price
because of the high demand put on it so
based on your current situation it is
very important that you plan out when
you're going to buy it and for how much
you're gonna buy it for for example do
you already have a pretty decent PC and
this is just an extra upgrade in that
case you may want to wait for the
holiday season of 2018 before buying a
gtx 1180 in order to take advantage of
all the deals that happen in that time
period
we'll be on to number 4 unfortunately
there are most likely be bugs associated
with the gtx 1180 because it is a new
launch and nvidia will most likely have
to correct some things after launch no
matter how much testing you do in a lab
there are a lot of bugs that rise only
with real-world experience for example
you may run into issues when you're
trying to overclock or your favorite
games may not support DirectX 12.5 or 13
so you maybe won't even be able to take
advantage of those features of the 1100
series pretty much all new technology
launches have issues at the beginning
and while most of them are minor it is
something to keep in mind because you
will have to deal with them if you
choose to buy a gtx 1180 in the imminent
future moving on to number 5 is your
build balance and does it actually make
sense for example are you trying to put
a rise in 12 wonder along with the gtx
1180 because in that case the rise in
1200 will most likely bottleneck
GTX 1180 and are you making sacrifices
in order to be able to afford the GTX
lab Navy for example are you taking out
an SSD in your bills to be able to go
from the GTX 1172 1180 in that case the
SSD would be a lot more useful because
in that scenario
NASA state will give you a lot better
performance than a gtx 1180 would over
the gtx 1170 so make sure your build is
balanced and it makes sense and that you
are not skimping out in one area in
order to be able to afford the gtx 1180
but in most cases the area that you're
skimping out on is more important than
just a GPU level finally on to number 6
well this is the most illogical and
irrational part of this video this is
also the most important thing to
consider which is how badly do you want
it this is really important because you
don't want to be unsatisfied with the
GPU that you buy for example let's say
that you really only need the
performance of a gtx 1170 but you really
want a gtx 1180 and you can afford it as
well you don't want to look at your PC
every day and be like I should have gone
with the gtx 1180 and every time your
frames dropped below 60 you don't want
to be thinking should have bought the
gtx 1180
so really make sure that you are fully
satisfied with whichever GPU you are
buying because you don't want to deal
with the unsatisfaction every single day
you were using your computer so those
are the six things that I think you
should consider before buying a gtx 1180
did I miss something really important
make sure comment down below what I
missed because I do read all my comments
and I'm curious as to what you guys
think so make sure to post your thoughts
also if you guys like this video then
make sure to drop a like and hit that
subscribe button if you guys would like
to see more videos just like this one
but until next time bye
[Music]